[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh rich eisen here
do you think anybody big names get
traded today
i don't think so dan um if i had to
choose a big name that that should get
traded today it should be cam to the
the dallas cowboys that would be
something that if i was dallas i'd i'd
kick the tires on
um but i just don't see anything like
that
there's no fantasy football trade in our
future over the next 10 hours i don't
think
if you're jj watt would you ask
to be traded without going to the media
right
would you ask behind the scenes i don't
i don't think so
um i i don't i don't know i look i don't
i don't profess to know exactly what's
in his head
i think he loves that city i think he
loves that town
um to answer your poll question i i
would take seattle if i
were him i know uh obviously packers is
his childhood team
but to me seattle is exactly what
um is is exactly what he would plug into
you know obviously when we're looking at
a post pandemic i've never been in a
place
where somebody's defensive play is
directly plugged into
the fans and how it actually turns into
a momentum changing play quite like
seattle i've never really seen anything
quite like it and the only thing that
comes close to it is
when jj watt makes a play in houston i
think it would be a perfect
perfect match it's exactly what they
need you even heard you know
collinsworth say a couple of sunday
nights ago
that where's the pass rush this is
exactly what this team needs they need
the pass rush carlos dunlap maybe
um you know uh a factor but i
i would love to see that marriage with
j.j watt in seattle i mentioned this to
peter king yesterday i said the longer
the season goes on the less i know
because we have all these injuries
you're not quite sure
if teams are going to be able to play
when they're supposed to play each
weekend
like it's this has been one big question
mark i i don't know who is great
i don't know who is really good i don't
know i know who's bad
your jets well
dan i i thought you were soft-paddling
all these nfl questions to you know get
me talking soften me up for
the michigan haymaker that you uh from
ohio
are about to deliver um you know uh i i
see it coming i understand you don't
normally telegraph your punches but i
definitely
have uh seen you uh at work for a
quarter century and know your style
um so this is an interesting way to
soften me up yes but yes the jets stink
on
ice to use the phrase that i heard quite
a bit growing up in new york city they
are terrible
they have broken sam darnold they should
sit him
i i i when i heard that they were giving
him an mri on his shoulder
that was so hurt in the game in denver
that
he came back into the game after leaving
it
only to have the jets even uh down two
scores
against denver shoehorn in another
dumbass personal foul penalty just
enough
to get darnold back on the field for
three useless snaps
i thought that they could use this mri
as cover to sit him down and start
flacco uh the rest of the year because
as you pointed out
uh in your uh third hour preamble that
there
are teams on their heels um with one win
that could absolutely use trevor
lawrence and would absolutely turn their
current starter into josh rosen to
continue the analogy
uh for trevor lawrence and the jets
should do that right now
they should say to sam darnold you are
great i think i heard you driving in
uh today to to the show here i think
pittsburgh would be an amazing spot for
him if jimmy g
is in fact uh maybe banged up to the
point where the niners would want to
move on i think he would be great
there too and the jets should send him
packing
um and give him what he deserves which
is a real opportunity in a franchise
that can handle it
for him uh and go get trevor lawrence
would you rather the jets didn't win a
game the rest of the season
or they won four oh i didn't stutter
i don't want to see them win a game the
rest of the season oh god no
what's the point what is the absolute
point so you could so you could feel
good about yourself well they did that
they screwed up last year right well but
there was no trevor lawrence in their
offering
offing um or even you know uh
this year's top three picks in the
offing really when they started
beginning to win again right i mean
there was there was nothing like that
so um right now they're in a great spot
this kid is ridiculously special and
he would be amazing in new york city
all the people saying you know he should
stay in school and tell the jets i'm not
coming
the jets can basically tell him at the
combine
uh you know we we got this coach um
you tell the enemy to bring andy reid's
playbook with him or
go go for it it's anybody and it's the
jets only an opportunity to get a coach
who would want to come to this franchise
it's it's a perfect situation
that they cannot screw up with a single
win over the next eight weeks dan
he's rich eisen the rich eisen show you
can find it on peacock right after this
show
and of course he is the nfl network host
which
should extend or expand playoffs just
for this season college football or the
nfl
college football right now i i don't
understand why they don't do it
this is a perfect opportunity for
whatever
politics has been preventing them from
doing the right thing and 18 play-off
is what we should see every year dan i
mean you know there's a team that's
fifth sixth seventh eighth
that has an opportunity to catch fire we
we also know that there's a team that
could be fifth or sixth
that deserves to be in the top four you
know you're already seeing now you know
i'm sure you're talking about the
clemson notre dame game that's on nbc
this weekend
um that you're already hearing like well
notre dame beats clemson oh you didn't
have
trevor lawrence playing well clemson
beat notre dame ellen
couldn't do it even without trevor
lawrence like it's going to be cut
either way
that uh is kind of a no-win situation
for notre dame
and uh we should remove i know it's it
adds a certain drama to this
week and because there's only four teams
but expanding it to eight see how it
goes i think
baseball showed the expanded playoffs
were entertaining
this year um and it had a march madness
type feel when it was a first pitch at
one and then it
kept cascading all the way throughout
the day for like four straight days i i
think college football should attempt it
since this is the day to vote you being
a michigan alum
and you had to vote oh wow jim harbaugh
at the end of the year oh my god you say
hey let's resign him or we say thank you
nice parting gifts this is the way
you're framing the question yes i am
this is the framing question so i'm at
the the polling place yes doesn't
yes i want him to stay how does that
sound i know
it has not been at all a
successful run in terms of national
championships and big ten championships
and beating ohio today
other than that it looks bad it looks
bad um and it is frustrating it's
very very frustrating to go through
saturdays like this
it's painful you lost the michigan
stayed at home
i'm very well aware that michigan and
state team that that turned it over
seven times against rutgers did not show
up in ann arbor on
saturday dan i mean let's be honest
they played mistake free football which
is kudos
to them in playing a rivalry game that i
wish
my school had won in a manner
that we saw michigan state pull it
together okay and you can you can blame
the coach but
who am i who am i hiring who am i hiring
am i hiring pj fleck i'm hiring matt
campbell
i mean who am i hiring just for the sake
of it hasn't worked out with one of
bozo's boys and is my first
quarterback you can't find a quarterback
when's the last time michigan had a
truly dangerous impressive
first-round talent quarterback i think
they have one right now actually
i really do i think he's live i really
do no no no i i really do but it's also
his second start
that's the problem like to me the
question i'm going to have and i already
have is why didn't this kid
have any run last year certainly when
shea patterson was having those two back
breaking turnovers
per game yeah that michigan couldn't
afford you know
i i i'm i know you know uh
everyone wants blood but honestly who
who would i hire
i'll i'll flip it to you like who should
michigan but are you
satisfied if this is going to be status
quo because it's been status quo
no i'm not i'm not satisfied i'm not
satisfied like 9 and 3
is you know that's nice for a lot of
colleges
but i know i am not satisfied i do not
like every single time michigan plays
that i have a pit in my stomach and i
look down at my text
and i see every ohio state friend of
mine giving me like the googly eyes
emoji like are you seeing this like yes
i am seeing this i am watching this it
stinks it is not a lot of fun
um and i you know and i don't understand
how michigan is actually favorite at
indiana
and i heard again driving in today you
called that a sneaky game it is not
sneaky i just
i'm not it's not sneaking up on me it's
not in it's not in my rearview mirror
it's right in front of me i saw how they
have played
they are inspired this is going to be
again one of their super bowls and
michigan does not play every week as if
the opponent
is playing them in their super bowl and
you can chalk that up to coaching
i just don't know who the alternative is
who's the person that i'm hiring fritz
i almost text you on saturday
oh no and i said and so he he texted me
to say should i text rich and i go no
no no no no no don't we we've done it
once before
i appreciate you being the human shield
for fritzy's
uh inanities i appreciate that man
um you know what at what point fritz
were you thinking about texting me was
it right when
when it was on the line uh when michigan
needed to
to score in that two-minute drive that
took 19 hours
for them to actually pull off when was
it i was just going to check in with you
like sunday night after the
broncos pulled off that comeback over
the charger so you couldn't get back to
me about denver
and once i got that second touchdown no
i wouldn't
first of all todd i don't take any
enjoyment
in anything that you find distressing
the only person i do that with is
mclovin
and i love going back at him on his
tweets that make no
sense like how many super bowls have
actually had pro bowl log receivers on
them not many that means wide receivers
don't mean anything as if
all pro uh i'm sorry it wasn't provo is
all pro wide receivers
as if that is the only metric by which a
quality receiver is measured
in being a championship quality like
tyrek hill the only guy who could make
that route
uh in the super bowl last year look as
beautiful as it did yes
it wasn't a pro it was an all problem
yes i know a team that could use some
all pro receivers and they play in ann
arbor that's all i'm saying oh my gosh
oh my gosh here's here's what i will
handle
i will handle dan giving me crap
because it literally we are working on
our second quarter century of that right
now
so i can handle that especially with him
from the state of ohio deep down dan i
don't i don't
you do enjoy michigan's um misery right
deep down the the ohio
the buckeye in you like i used to i used
to
i used i felt sorry for michigan when i
was at the ohio state game a couple of
years ago
like i felt sorry for them which one was
that the 60 burger or the one with the
fourth down that jt barrett did not
actually get
no it wasn't the 60 60 points they gave
him i felt
sorry for them i wanted i want the right
i want it to be a rivalry
no i i would sew it up
okay what hurt more michigan state or if
you lost to ohio state
or the michigan state lost what hurts
more oh ohio stage
are you you're you you should expect to
lose to ohio state
no we don't accept no no you should we
should know we should know we should not
yes no
michigan state you lost to michigan
state at home it's not
ag i'm again aware of you're alone i'm
willing to take it
[Laughter]
and flip college football i will not
accept that okay this aggression will
not stand dan it will not
paul do you have a question for isaac
richards
are you glad you came on of course okay
i always enjoy this uh seton do you have
a question for rich einstein
no let him go okay all right no no his
awesome wife does the voiceovers for my
program so
we're we're we're a seaton friendly
family um
so does paul you got nothing nobody i'm
just glad you came on rich good to have
you back
who's uh who's yes mclovin does rich
know that rutgers beat michigan hey i
just wanted to make sure that that was
on the yeah he did mention that yeah i
did mention that uh who's on the show
coming up
uh we have today uh malcolm jenkins um
who is going to be covering antonio
brown rick stroud to talk about the
the bucks uh victory and taking on the
saint scapioli for
a little bit of a conversation for trade
deadline and uh ron rivera riverboat ron
will be
honestly awesome tell everybody in the
building we said hello is anybody left
in the building
everybody we're socially distant there's
not many people left here but uh
we're here and uh and i look forward to
uh being on after your showdown
thank you buddy that's rich eisen